very often when we do these things we
show up with a selfish disposition
right I hope they like me I hope they
like my work I hope they buy my book I
hope they you know go to my website I
hope they follow me on social media and
and we act that way you know we put us a
picture behind us on the PowerPoint and
it has our all of our social media
handles on it and has a phone number and
a website and an email address right and
we say at the end you know somebody
asked the questions like you know
question whatever and they and we reply
well you'll have to read my book or well
that's on that's from my book you know
and it's like it's we put ourselves and
that's people can tell
and in those cases we're not rooting for
you in fact we're going to try and trip
you up right because we can't help
ourselves it's entertaining yes you know
you put yourself at the front we'll have
fun with that and so I've I've learned
early to show up with a givers mentality
um where I don't care if uh if they like
me I don't care if they buy a book I
don't care if they follow me on social
media or not all I know is is I have
something that I think is really
valuable and I'm gonna give it to you I
want to give it to you and I believe I'm
giving you with all of my Gusto and all
of my energy and so like I remember you
know people would apologize because they
you know they said there's going to be
this size event and like only half the
number of people showed up and they're
apologizing and I know a lot of speakers
who'd get angry you promised me this
size audience and I was like well I just
feel sorry for the people who didn't
show up because the people who did show
up are gonna get all of me right you
know
um I hold back nothing
um and I think when you show up with a
giver's heart and I literally will say
that before I go out on a stage I would
literally say under my breath before I
step on the stage you're here to give I
will remind myself
that what I'm about to do is is an act
of generosity I think I have something
pretty and I want to share it and people
can tell yeah authenticity people can
tell and so you you have a wide birth
when you show up with the giver's heart
you can make mistakes and you can
stumble over your words and you can you
can talk a little bit too much like I am
right now and people are just fine with
it yeah you know
um so I think you know we're highly
attuned social animals and if you show
up to give you you can you believe it or
not you can you can experiment a lot